[Music]  first day new job always exciting  starting a new job sun is shining makes  it a little bit better need to get used  to doing these videos while walking  because people probably think I'm a  weirdo but yeah super excited and yeah  looking forward to it  great first day really really enjoyed it  what I love about working for a small  business is you get to build  relationships with every single person  in the business who you spend loads of  time with particularly with the  directors which are really like because  they're the people that you're putting  the work in and I think it's just really  really fruitful having relationships  with those people so yeah really really  enjoyed today and just so so excited  felt so right me by it being there and  yeah [ __ ] buzzin